Mike I understand you went to LA Film
School that's all right yep okay so how
was that for you do you feel that it was
worth it for you in the end yeah I did
the producing major and cinematography
major at le film school now over 10
years ago right to class 2003 and back
then the big thing was filmed you know
we we had access to film people were
shooting on super 16 and if you were
lucky enough you got to shoot on 35 so
we we ended up getting a grant from
Panavision and Kodak and we actually
shot our thesis project there on 35 mil
and so it was like kind of the ultimate
because you're students so you can sort
of like say hey we're students and then
everyone kind of contributes to your
project because you're a student and so
we ended up basically getting several
hundred thousand dollars of expenses or
donations or effort or free camera
rentals or these kinds of things because
we were students so that was exciting to
sort of like get to make something that
you wouldn't have been able to make if
you weren't a student so those times
were very interesting you know editing
on these old avid computers with like I
remember the hard drives that we're
editing or like 125 game you know 250
gig ide drives and it was like and you
had to edit in proxy all these little
avid files things are way different now
so aside from what you learn from
lectures or in class participation what
did you witness from your teachers that
you took with you into your projects
just from their work ethic or how they
approached people yeah when I was there
at LA Film School several of our
teachers were actually working also and
so they were just off this set of big
movies as a production designer or had
just had a muscle you know had just had
an awful failure at a big-time movie and
now could tell you what they did wrong
so it's sort of like learning from
people that were like actually had the
experiences to talk about
which is really cool i remember my
producing you know instructor had kind
of these horror stories of how things go
wrong and so in producing class we kind
of like would learn about things like
that right what were some of the stories
can you share like without may be naming
specific yeah you know just just big
sets and and you know things gone wrong
with nature and waiting for rain and
delayed days and problems with actors
and you sort of like oh wow man what am
i getting into here but you know you
push through it and you learn various
things you know cinematography class
just just I'm you know getting to meet
some of these amazing cinematographers
and talk about lighting and just so you
know the people that know their craft
that have been in it already for a
decade and you kind of get those
experiences in school you kind of get to
see through their eyes like some tips on
what they've gone through and so in a
nutshell did they leave you with any
like sayings or pieces of wisdom in
terms of like look this is what you want
to do it's it's 10 times less glamorous
than it appears uh well I remember at
the time uh you know we were in writing
classes also we took all the writing
classes there till a film school and one
of the big things was whoa you know
you're writing kid parts into your
scripts here like you want to stay away
from that definitely stay away from kids
and stay away from animals because
they're going to be chaos on your set
and like you want to have an easy time
here don't do it don't do it and this
was like hey this was told to us but we
were like you know we know kids that are
awesome and we're going to do it anyways
and so in our thesis project we ended up
working with like a whole children's
choir you know 20 kids on sad news we
did and they were they behaved yeah yeah
yes it was good in terms of
misconceptions people have about film
school what would you tell people ahead
of time like suppose there was someone
that was maybe graduating high school
and that was their plan was to go the
same route what would be some of the
things you
sell them be aware of this or that not
that that particular school was bad but
in terms of the idea of what they would
get yeah I'm a film school education I
think you know one of the biggest things
about film school is that it
automatically brings together
collaborators because your class is
another 30 kids that are also doing the
same thing and so the contacts you meet
the fellow filmmaking teams to meet I
mean some of the people that I know made
connections back then that are still
working together today on shoots dps
that shot directors projects or
producers that are working with
directors so the partnerships that you
make in school end up being you know
sometimes being really solid forever I
mean it's like it's like an automatic
friendship maker basically you know you
put together with all these other people
that are around the same age and you're
all wanting to make the same thing to do
the same thing to work on movies so it's
a you know i would say i would say like
you know take advantage of it because
you're going to be in a scenario where
you're never going to get you know
20,000 feet of free film again right so
do it both that was ten years ago but
free camera rentals or free lighting
packages or whatever you get as being a
student take advantage of it and like
make something that you wouldn't be able
to make out you know otherwise
you